every time there's another mass shooting
in America
politicians have the same idea it's time
to require a background check for anyone
who wants to buy a gun I'm one of the
Republicans who does believe they treat
background checks it is an open secret
that the existing background check
system is broken oh I have an appetite
for background checks we're gonna be
doing background checks here's what they
want to change right now gun buyers in
the US only have to go through a
background check at a gun store but they
don't have to go through one if they buy
a gun from an unlicensed dealer like at
a gun show or a private sale but with
universal background checks everyone who
buys a gun would have to go through one
pretty much every American is in favor
of this there's only one problem
universal background checks won't solve
America's gun crisis but there's
something else that might to understand
how background checks work it helps to
imagine two very different people who
both want to buy a gun the first person
is dangerous maybe he has a history of
domestic violence or mental illness and
most importantly he has a record and the
second one is not dangerous he just
wants a gun for protection or to go
hunting or cuz shooting guns is kind of
fun before either one can buy a gun they
first have to go through an FBI instant
background check and I mean instant it
only takes an average of a hundred eight
seconds to get a response from the FBI's
database that database is made up of
records sent in by State Police and
other agencies and it's checked to see
if the buyer has things like a criminal
record addiction a restraining order or
has been hospitalized for a mental
illness under a universal background
check system anyone buying a gun whether
in a gun store or through a private sale
would have to be checked through that
database that means our second person
walks out with a gun and our first
person with a criminal record doesn't or
at least he shouldn't I've done a lot of
reporting on this we have just seen time
and time again the background checks do
not stop people who we don't want having
guns from actually getting the weapons
there are a couple problems with the
background check system one is that the
FBI database is about as outdated as its
it's missing millions of records that's
why the Charleston Church shooter was
able to buy a gun despite having a
record or why the man who killed 26
Texan churchgoers was also able to pass
a background check after the Air Force
failed to send his domestic abuse
convictions to the FBI so even with a
background check for every type of sale
there's still a chance this guy gets a
gun that's partly why study after study
has found that while background checks
prevent or make substantially more
difficult the criminal acquisition of
firearms making them universal doesn't
have any effect on the actual gun crisis
in America gun deaths a Johns Hopkins
study of California where comprehensive
background checks were implemented in
1991 found that the law was not
associated with changes in firearms
suicide or homicide thanks in part to
those incomplete and missing records the
other problem with background checks is
that they only look at good people and
already bad people but there is an in
between the background checks are
supposed to catch people who have a
record already it just misses all the
people who haven't done anything bad yet
but might do something bad in the future
hermod is not advocating for a minority
reports situation he's talking about
someone like this guy who's also
dangerous but who doesn't have a record
under a universal background check
system he could get a gun in a hundred
and eight seconds but there's another
system that could prevent this 12 states
in DC have gone one step further and
established a licensing system how is it
different well here's how it works in
Massachusetts before you ever go to a
gun store you first have to take a
firearm safety course then you have to
go to the police department and submit
an application give references and give
your fingerprints for a background check
then not only is the FBI database
checked but all local law enforcement
agencies wherever you've lived are
directly contacted along with the
Department of Mental Health that entire
process in Massachusetts usually takes
about three weeks and most people about
97% pass
nothing about a licensing system will
prevent a law-abiding citizen from going
through the process and obtaining a
firearm that's dr. Cassandra Kerr Fosse
she researches health policy Johns
Hopkins and she's one of the authors
from the studies earlier she says the
reason licensing works is that it's
designed to do both of the big things
background checks fail at a to properly
identify and screen out people who
shouldn't have guns and be create a
system to reduce impulsive gun purchases
the licensing system is more
comprehensive than the one database
background check system so our criminal
will be reliably denied a gun but
because it's so meticulous it also
stands a chance of keeping our third guy
without a record from getting a gun
there are people who may want to
impulsively acquire a firearm for
example to harm themselves or others and
the process of obtaining a license can
at least delay that person during that
time of crisis or you know maybe deter
them from getting that firearm at all in
1995 Connecticut implemented a licensing
system over the next 10 years they saw a
drop in gun homicides and gun suicides
compare that to Missouri which once had
a licensing system but got rid of it in
2007 over the next decade they had a
huge spike in gun homicides and gun
suicides in both states there were lots
of factors involved but researchers say
this shows that licensing works it's
also pretty popular among voters who
live in a house with a gun more than
two-thirds think that it's a good idea
ask all Americans and more than 3/4
support it background checks are
supposed to stop bad people from getting
guns but they often don't licensing
picks up that slack by making sure that
people are crossing these hurdles we
just make sure in a much better stronger
way that people are not getting firearms
when they shouldn't have them